so morys fragt wann kommt der rap mit
goma hd das ist eine sehr interessante
frage weil milch komme dazu letztes
angeschrieben hat alle meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen hier zu
einer weiteren folge hashtag fragt luca
weil ich spiele minecraft hide and seek
und ihr hattet ihr heute schon ein video
und zwar habe ich heute mal wieder die
kräftig ideen hochgeladen übrigens wenn
ihr euch da wundert warum da so ein
komisches land mel ist ich hab mich
etwas neues probiert aber ich finde
irgendwie sieht jedenfalls habe ich mir
gedacht hey eigentlich sollte ich mal
nicht mehr den output und zwar ist es ja
eigentlich so bei mir so ich mache ein
bisschen aufwendigere serien möchte ich
jetzt mal so uneigennützig irgendwie
behaupten weil ich daher halt schon ein
bisschen immer längere sätze an
effektvoll gesetzlich halt bis zu einer
stunde an bearbeiten ist natürlich nicht
viel aber ich mache das ganze täglich
und allein und geht natürlich noch zur
schule und so also die stets uni und
weiter aber ich habe mir jetzt gedacht
diese hashtag fragt kasachen sind ja
relativ unaufwendig produziert also ich
machen park hat und mir vor die wii
sowie so kann ich das hallo
wieso kann ich die tür nicht aufmachen
er kann die wohl auch nicht aufmachen
irgendwie friesacher alter also diese
fragt luca videos diese minecraft halten
stick sachen sind halt nur ich suche mir
die fragen heraus fragt dabei twitter
und nehmen ein paar fragen meistens
irgendwie zehn stück und beantwortete
die dann einfach und schneider ein
bisschen einfach damit ein bisschen
anschaulicher wird
und da hatte ich mir gedacht ich weiß
nicht was ihr davon haltet also dass ich
das mal ein bisschen öfters bringe also
einfach so fragen beantworten und dass
so alle zwei drei tage man hochladen
damit ihr nicht jeden tag noch ein video
von mir ab viele beschweren sich ja naja
was heißt viele einige beschweren sich
ja immer darüber dass aber ich habe noch
gar kein opti feldern oder rhade
aber ich hab den summen auf einer
anderen taste das ganze schneiden kann
als schon mal dazu führen dass na ja
einige leute meinen dass das so ein
bisschen zu hektisch sei die videos und
die freuen sich dann immer auf dieses
dieses fragen beantworten weil das ein
bisschen ruhiger ist deswegen bruder das
auf jeden fall ein richtiger als
versteck hier
man muss ehrlich sagen man sieht gar
nicht dazu
jetzt stehen dem theoretisch kann mir
einen baum machen
moment ich bin ein
wir sind baum tatsache wird vielleicht
nicht das allerbeste versteckt aber
da ist ein ca wieso ist der hinter der
wand ab damit dass man mein fuß jörg
kelter
was ist los ich hab möglich am fuß das
kann doch nicht sein sieht man dass da
ich glaub nicht oder also viele meinen
ja mach doch mal wieder sowas cory
schneider für dich zu fuß oder mit das
ganze ein bisschen ruhiger ist deswegen
hab ich mir gedacht einfach eine ganz
gute sache bevor ich jetzt mit den
fragen wie immer an fange einfach was
haltet ihr davon wenn nicht so alle zwei
drei tage mal so zwischendurch zu als
keine ergänzung zu diesem geschnittenen
videos dass sich dazu einfach dann mal
so eine fragerunde hochladen wo ich
einfach so ein bisschen schillig redet
zeigt mir mit einer bewertung oder mit
einem chat kommentar oder irgendwie
doppelter schmerz vielleicht dachte er
auch nicht einen wieder unterricht uns
von dir aber wir sind ja hier um fragen
zu beantworten also die erste frage
kommt von junos pulse was hältst du von
tunneln
ach so bruder du willst hier ich gehe
weg damit du dahin kannst bist oder
nicht
hätte nicht der richter ich finde mit
tunneln und piercings allgemein ist das
ist nicht wahr
jetzt kann ich die tür wieder nicht
öffnen kennt jemand von euch den fehler
oder oder oder wie oder was ich kann die
tür nicht öffnen mut ich wollte
eigentlich umlaufbahn bleibe ich oben
stehen ich finde die sache mit mit
piercings tunneln also ich hoffe mal du
meinst den tunnel als piercing so im ohr
oder irgendwie als tunnel wo man als
autor unter festival wo man als auto
runter fährt wo man durchfährt aber ich
denke du meinst in den ohren
ich selber könnte mir bei mir nicht so
gut vorstellen weil ich habe relativ
kleine ohren wenn man das sowieso
mir wird immer gesagt ich hab doch luca
du hast du kleine tüte um wieder ein
welpe und bei der nasa soll auch ganz
klein und sein meinen die allem aber ich
finde mir selbst glaube ich würd's nicht
stehen aber ich finde bei mädchen kommt
zum auf den typ bei manchen mädchen ich
mache eigentlich gar keine tattoos aber
manche mädchen sehen ob da tust geil
lena fragt würdest du dich als person
mit humor bezeichnen ja aber ich würde
mich als person mit einem sehr
abgepackten humor bezeichnen ich kann
aber so verrückte sachen machen ich kann
mich total kaputt lachen wenn sie so
einen typ durch innenstadt läuft und so
haare hat wie so ein borsten wie sollen
so an den seiten so mega kahl rasiert
vielleicht ein idiot oben also zehn
zentimeter so
umso irokese mäßig darüber kann ich mich
kaputtlachen wie sonstwas einfach über
über über komische dinge über
irgendwelche leute die total auf die
fresse fliegen so schadenfreude ist
genau mein ding aber ich liebe auch
einfach seinen humor wie irgendwie
stromberg oder oder irgendwie sowas kann
der mich nicht hier raus wollen kommen
da ist dieser diese beruhten hier raus
ich komme nicht durch die tür also ich
weiß nicht ich kann es selbst nicht so
beurteilt ich denke jeder mensch hat
humor aber auf eine andere art und weise
außer sheldon cooper
das ist wirklich ein humorloser fällt
ein schüler frage was würdest du machen
wenn er die chance hat ist eine frau zu
sein
ich denke ich würde mir wünschen wieder
einmal zu sein ich weiß ich bin
zufrieden mit mir mit meinem körper mit
meinem geschlecht von daher ist es ganz
okay und ich möchte hier aus ist es ihr
vorbei von daher wir haben gewonnen aber
sein recht langweilige runde und ich
hänge natürlich noch eine runde hin
hallo freunde die nächste runde ist
jetzt los gegangen ich bin ein quatsch
glock ich einfach mal hier hingestellt
ich weiß nicht ob das jemand bemerkt
also ich würde sagen ich möchte
eigentlich keine frau sein also wenn ich
die ist wieder gefragt wenn ich die
chance hätte dass ich eine frau sein
könnte dann würde ich die chance auf
jeden fall nicht agrar japan schreibt
swiss bestimmt mit maxwell hashtag luca
kennst du den kurzfilm von der manchmal
denke ich es geht mir genauso würdest du
es auch so machen wie er den er hat ihr
dieses diese partnerschaft damit dieser
techniker krankenkasse oder irgendwie
sowas gemacht meine ich und ich denke
mal du sprichst das an mit dieser wir
einfach wer merkt dass einfach nicht
immer sein kollege schon oh mein gott
wie witzig und fähig versuchten jetzt
irgendwie auf den anderen blockiert zu
lenken dass der mich ein innerer
leichten später oder wo ist der alte ich
verstecke mich einfach nicht verstecken
ich gehe hier hin hier kann ich nicht
hier hin kein platz ich glaube hier ist
mega gut oder
hier bleibt jetzt einfach mal stehen
hatte sie hat gefragt es so damit der
sache mit mit denen das filme den film
dann geht's halt ging es halt darum dass
er damals studiert hat und youtube
gleichzeitig und kann damit überhaupt
nicht klar und so und ich muss selber
sagen ich fühle mich so ein bisschen wie
er weil ich halt auch studiere und
nehmen bei youtube mache und ich auch
recht wenig schlaf also ich darf
mittlerweile pro nacht zu 45 stunden
aber bissig nicht irgendwie mal
der schäden von trage wenn ich das auf
jeden fall erstmal beides weiterhin
nebenbei laufen lassen würde ist halt
nur das zurzeit klausurphase ist und ich
auch meine facharbeit jetzt gefährlich
schreiben muss um eine studienarbeit und
so und deswegen es ist zurzeit halt ein
bisschen stressig aber ich denke wenn
man seine zeit gut plant und nicht immer
bis mittags im bett liegt wenn man
erkennen kann dann kriegt man das auf
jeden fall beide sind ein gut das heißt
ich denke nicht dass ich da schon
totalen kollaps kriegen wäre die fragt
ob ich aggressiv werde wenn ich hunger
habe
nee ich werde nicht aggressiv aber ja
doch eigentlich schon aggressiv aber ich
werde auf meine ergänzt aggressiv ich
wäre dann so richtig wie so ein kleiner
who
ich lasse mich glaube ich einfach töten
das nehme ich mir solls vorwand wenn ich
verfolgt werden und ihr keine chance
mich verfolgt ich bin also ein bisschen
gleis nicht man sollte dann eigentlich
nicht mit mir reden weil ich dann bin
ich so aggressiv aber ich bin super
halt's maul er doch eigentlich schon
abgesteckt luca wirst du wieder mal nach
österreich ski fahren
ja ich bin im märz dort da in tirol
wieder höher bei der nähe
da werde ich da so ein bisschen seien
aber nur vier tage und da werde ich dann
auch nochmal an kündigen weil ich davor
auch in münchen bin wegen anderen sachen
nicht youtube technisch aber vielleicht
da nach münchen muss und dann verbinde
ich das einfach und dann ist meine
familie schon das skifahren und ich gehe
dann dahin und fliegt dann von münchen
aus dahin oder oder widmen auto für den
weg oder irgendwas keine ahnung auf
jeden fall bin ich im märz da und
natürlich jedes jahr weihnachten bin ich
eigentlich nation ist drewitz pvp oder
wyss ich weiß es nicht genau
hashtags luca was ist jetzt mit hero 2.0
hast du schon andere youtuber darüber
geredet
ich habe noch nicht mit anderen user
darüber geredet weil es ja nur eine
frage war was ich davon halten würde und
nicht ob ich mal so was planen könnte
weil ich und planen ist immer so ein
leben kriege ich organisatorisch schon
alles hin oder wenn es darum geht für
ein paar kollegen abendessen zu
organisieren dass man mit mit 20 mann
dann dass jeder irgendwie da zeit hat
oder so dass krieg schon noch hin aber
so ein projekt auf die beine zu stellen
mit regeln und alle möglichen da das
sollen andere leute machen das haben wir
bei wago auf glaube ich glp und taten
übernommen
die können sich ganz gut aber ich möchte
also das bmwi hero 2.0 wer ganz cool das
war ich denke ich jeder aber da ist
glaube ich schon was anderes und planung
von den leuten die auch im aura waren
daher kann nicht sein dass ich ihn halt
finden ich glaube die leute die in
europa waren wollten da sein neues
projekt machen unter den untereinander
das haben ja gesagt dass aura und
übergangs projekt von denen ist zu einem
anderen geilen projekt es wird sich
zeigen wer da alles dabei ist aber wenn
wenn einige nicht dabei sind wird man
mit denen vielleicht was machen oder
irgendwie so ich muss auch gucken ob ich
demnächst bei solchen großen projekt
immer noch dabei sein möchte weil war
bin ich direkt rausgeflogen und auch
jetzt galaxy jeweils nicht ganz so geil
fand ich aber mal schauen wie sich das
alles entwickelt aber hero 2 ich noch
keinen zu angesprochen um auf die frage
zurückzukommen so morys fragt wann kommt
der rap mitkomme hd das ist eine sehr
interessante frage weil ich komme dazu
letztes angeschrieben hatte so erstmal
wieder burg aufzunehmen ist eigentlich
stinkt's mittel der nachher werde nicht
halt einfach so angeschrieben mit dem
rap eigentlich könnten wir nicht mal
angriff nehmen weil wir den eigenbestand
vormonat machen wollten
aber irgendwie so wenig dazugekommen und
mancher ist auf jeden fall in arbeit
also zumindest habe ich einen beat aber
ich hab noch keinen text und will ich
weiß nicht ob wir den rapper jetzt so
richtig scheiß machen oder versuchen ihr
gut zu machen oder irgendwo muss schon
vorbei auf jeden fall wieder noch kommen
früher oder später aber er wird kommen
und jetzt kommt auch schon zur letzten
frage weil ich mir gedacht habe ich hab
jetzt wenig letzte mal bin ich nach der
halte ich dieses charlie hebdo video
gemacht habe was danach dass sich in der
lobby bisschen herum gelaufen bin und
allemal
das gameplay vorbei hybride leute zu
viel in der lobby um man weiß nicht das
ist richtiges paco irgendwie könnte dir
wird im lauf ich mal aufgefallen dass
ich die ganzen letzten videos mann und
dunkeln gedreht habt also immer nur wenn
so zwei fette softbox mich an leuchtend
ich total fertig aussehen
das zeigt wie viel zeit ich hör auf zu
viel zu lachen das nicht wird sich also
letzte frage
hendrik fragt hashtags luca was
studierst du genau etwas im
medienbereich oder eine ganz andere
richtung das ist eine recht interessante
frage die ich unglaublich auf gefragt
weil ich hätte nie gedacht dass so viele
leute interessiert was ich studiere ich
möchte das allerdings nicht sagen weil
ich nehm bereich halt auch später
arbeiten möchte ist ein thema das mich
sehr interessiert ist hat nicht so viel
mit youtube zu tun aber ich habe mich
halt schon dafür entschieden so etwas zu
studieren
als ich noch nicht mit youtube
angefangen habe sage ich mal das ist
jetzt nicht so dass youtube gezeigt hat
wo du hast an dem zahlmeister interesse
sondern ich habe mir das schon vorher
ausgemalt ok dazu möchte auf jeden fall
machen
deswegen habe ich auch letztes in dem
video gesagt wenn ich mit youtube wenn
ich mir das alles zu viel wird mit
youtube und studium wäre ich auf jeden
fall mit youtube auf da sollte sich sein
dass ich mit youtube auf höre ich hab
euch abholen schon gesagt ja ich krieg
das zurzeit noch alles unter einen hut
mal schauen wie es läuft aber ich möchte
auf jeden fall nicht mit dem studieren
aufhören weil das macht mir spaß
da ich brauche ich brauche einfach weil
ich kann nicht mein leben damit
verbringen
youtube zu machen und reisen oder und
einfach so zu hause zu sitzen und videos
aufzunehmen
ich muss irgendwie immer so nerlich habe
man dieses ehrgeiz mäßig ich habe mir
gesagt ja irgendwann später möchte auf
jeden fall erfolgreich sein und alles
ist habe ich mir gesagt sorry dass ich
schon wieder in der lobby rumlaufe aber
ja ich versuche ich das ganze ein
bisschen näher zu bringen also youtube
ist eine sache dass es mega cool macht
mir spaß und würdig an ich würde es ja
nicht machen quasi
aber es ist jetzt halt so wenn wir
wirklich alles zu viel wird menschen mit
youtube auf aber weil man das studium
halt so viel spaß macht das genaue mir
daran so viel spaß macht ist einfach
weil's genommen ein thema ist es ist
genau das wofür ich mich interessiere
ich glaub ich hab das mal alten videos
gesagt es hat auf jeden fall nicht mehr
viel mit youtube zu tun aber ich möchte
es erstmal nicht tragen weil mir das zu
weit in die privatsphäre geht genau
solche sachen wie hey wo genau wohnst du
oder irgendwie sowas in die richtung
aber ich würde schon sagen damit war es
das für die runde hashtag partner für
heute wenn ihr mehr von diesen videos
wollt die ich zwischendurch hoch lade
ich sehe jetzt das was ich total
verpennt aussehe und meine haare total
scheiße sind in dem mehr solcher videos
wollt wo ich einfach zu den
geschnittenen videos wie folgt oder
commerce oder mops oder irgendwie was
noch diese sachen hochladen wo ich
natürlich auch schneider aber nicht so
viel dann zeigt es mit einer bewertung
und folgt auf twitter wenn ihr bei der
nächsten chat café damit ein